[موسيقى]
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف قصف بتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قضاء فعشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قذائف العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من اكبر
مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمه مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر
دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار لفتح
مسارات امنه لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه
للمدنيين وان تحققت لفتره فثمت تحولات
عسكريه بين حين واخر قد تجعل الحاله اكثر
ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات